♪ ♪
>> I JUS CHEING MY WATCHT
THE DAY I USULY WCH THIS FORND E
HSE,OW IET TO LIVE I
WE TN N TO FOX NEWS
CONTBUTO RAYMONDRROY ALSOTO CATS
EKEND ON MY SHOWNE NION,
AND A "N YORTIMES" OP-ED.
I SHIS SITES I LANDMAR
HE CLAIMTHAT ARCEUNKER
WOULD'VE VOT FOR DONALD TRUMP,
T ALSO WOULD'V ABAONED
TRUMAFTER JUARY 6.
HE CTINU THE SEEN.
WOULD'VEEEN ALLY UPSET TO
SEE COPS BEATENY INSURGES
AND TH TOINDUT A TIME
GO BY THA DONALTRUM WAS AT
THE HUB O ALLHIS AND IT WAS
DONA TRUMP'S OPERAONAL
TOGEER IHINK H WOU'VE
GONEHE WAY O LIZ CHENEY AND
AD KINNGER.
>>OB REINER IS GRE
DICTOR OF POKON ARCHI IS
FIIONA CRACT.
M KIND O DISRBED THAT WE
HAVE REACHED A POINT WHERE TSE
CREATI'S ARE NOW TURNING TSE
LOVED SITCOM CRACTERS INTO
POLICAL AVATARS.
SUGGESTI THATHE GOLDEN GIRWOULDI
BEUSE  KEPT ON ROLNG T
THANDEMIC.
CHANGE THEIRARTY AILIATIONBEUSEN
NEW YORK CIT.
OR MBE THERE A SPLIT IN THE
MONSTER FAMY THEY AATTENDINA TMT
GRANDP HAS FLINGOR L
ENEY'S REELECTN CAAIGN.
THESE ARFICTNAL CHARACTS,
THEIR BELOD A THEY OULDO
TOY WITH IN THIS WAY
INTERVIEW HER HIS LAS
TERVW ALMOST MY LT BUHIS
LAST INTERVI ANDE OFTEN
LKEDBOUT THE TENSIS WI
AND EVEN O'CAOLL OONNELLR.
S --
YET SOUCH RPECT FOR THECHARACTES
REESENNG THAT IS PT OF
AMERA THAT MAY BE WA
RICATURED INNE W THEY
WOD OEN FHT OVER THE
RECTN OF THECRIPAND THE
CHARACR.
>> Brian: YOUNOWHAT YOU
MAY BE THI OF EN HE WT
THROUGALLHESE GREAT SHOWS?
HOWNBELIEVABLE SITMS A
MILIES GOT TETHE AND
WITHTREAMING IN A THEABLEW
CHANLS,  DON'TEEHAT ER
HAPPENG AGN DO Y?
>> TY BRGHT GENERATNS
TOGETHND LOOK AT PEOE WANT
FINE. A POLITIC VIEOINT
HA AUND-RAISER,ONATE,
RAISE UR VOICEOME UP WITTHE TE E
THND TURN  AGAST PART OF
E POPULACE I JT TNK IT'S
OFF LIMS.
JUST THINK IT'BAD FM.
>> Bri: RIGHT.
I NEEDOUREACTION TO THIS,
BEYOE MA HEADLINES TOD IS
PROMING  REMOVE AND
OFFENSIVE WD FR HEREW SG
CAED HEAD?
>> ALL THAT T AUDIEE TE
I DE Y LISTEN. OF TS LYRIC
♪♪
♪ ♪
[BLEEP].
>> UNG FOR,PAZ IS T
FENSE TERM AND AT LYRIC.
APPANTLY SOMOF T DISLED
COMMITY HAS RAISECONCNS
OUT THI
TH SAYHAT SPAIS TT IT
DIMINISHES THOSE WHOAN'T
CONTL THEIR MUSES SOEYON
ISEMOVING THE WOR SPA
NER MI THAT IT CONTINU ON
THAT BACKSIDE, BUTHAT IS
PERFECTLYINE.
I DOHINKHATE WENTHE WT
FARNOUGWITH THELEAN AND
THE LYRICS.
Bri: DO YOU LIKEHENOU
T A LITTLE B OLDER AND Y
MEOW.
REALLY SEEN HEIN A WHI,T
MILDHANVER BNG OUT X-RATED
LYRI, PS WT ABOUT THE
DIMPLED COMMUNITY?
ARE T UNSALTED BYEINGSED
IN HER SONS QUTION WHAT CAN
THOUT ABT THAT?
>> RHT?
THOSWITH SETCH MK WON
USE HER LYRS IT WRITT
BYRAKENCIDENTAY.
HE WRO THO LOVELY LICS WHY
YOU'D SIN THEAS A RENOWNED
MAN O YOUNGEOPL LOOK UP
TO I D'T QTE GETHAT?
>> Ban: ANDONDEULLY PUT
TOGETHER QUICK POEY TRE
'LL  DOWN IN HISRY
[LAUS]
LIZZA FEW WEE AGOEMOV
THEAME RIC A FEWEEKS A
OM HER SONG GIR.
♪
[BLE]  ♪
>> UERSTD HOW PEOPLEET
QUESTION IS T INTTIONITYE
WHHERHEY WERENTENONALLY
MANG FUN OF A COMMUNITY WIT
THEORD.
IN THAT COEXT E REALLY
ISN' BUTHE TOOECIDED T
MOVE TT WD ABOUT TEACHG
UNG GIRLS OFMERICA I
PERFTLY FINE TO RER TO YOUNGWOMH
THE B-WORD WON REPEAT IT.
JUST DON'T GET WHY THI
COARNING OF LANAGE D TRASH
TALK ISCCEPTABLE ANDET WE
FINDHIS NYITTLE WORD TT
ONLY OENDSEOPLE IF YOU
REAL LOONG FORT AN THAT'THE ONE.
IT MAKES NO NSEOE.
>> Ban: ISUST SO FUN AND
PREPINGOR T SEGNT I'VE
NEVE SEEN MOREASHEAND
CLAMATIONS INIFFERENT TES
OF SBOLS FRO AEYBOD.
SUMS LIKE THE
"WHE OF FORTUNE" A THE
BEGIING OF A PZLE.
I N'TVEN KNOWHE INTENTION
LL GET ONE, TWO LETTERS BEFE
'VE FENDED SEONET THE
FCC.
WE WILL REMO O
>> W THAAME
Brian: HAV SOMEONEO
USE RE TMS TO UNDERSTD
TH T FRONT SING AUT.
REARCHS 2 O MILLEIALS
ARE VINGITH THEIR PARTS
THAT'S U 9% FRO 1971.
>>HAT WAS BACK WN MEATHEA
WAS LEING TH ARCHIUNKER,
NOA SAH LAWRENCEPROFESSOIS SGEST
THISOULDE GOOD FOR ARICA.
WRITESHAT ERE IS APOIBLEILVER E
NEY RENSTITUTED MULTHANN
RETIONALOUSELDS.
THEY MAY HELP U IMPRO OUR
MOCRACYHARI SPACES WITH
MILY MEMRS M ALSO COMPEMORE POLA
APOVE R LONELINESS EDEMI
AMG YOG AMERINS
NOW BRI, HE A 30-AR-OLD ILIVINGN
BY THEIR CHOE HOPEFULLY T
LEON WOU BEEEEDETTER
OPRTUNITIES SO WCAN L LIVE
DEPENDENTLY A GROAS
DIVIDUALEOPLE.
THAT SHOULD  THE FIR LESN,
D I'MOT OPPOSED TTHEM
LIVI TOGETHER THAS A GD
THING EN GERATIONSRE
TOTHER.
MY QUEION IS WHEN Y HAV AN
ECONOMY THSTINTHE SITE YNG
PEOPLE IS NOTSSERVE
GRANDMA SSEDHE SWEET A LOWn Y, T
IS N SUMNG I WANT TO BE
SAYI, BUI'D ALSOAY THIS.
T.
EY SM TO HA DON FE
RIGHT THETATEUT FROM
NEW YORK SMAYB WE CANEARN
RIM AND I THEAD NS.ERLL.
ES?
WATCH FORUT OECK MY
ALL HAVE TOOACK AND WATCH
ALL IN TH FILY RERS.
I'LL S YOU THIS WEEKE AND
HO YOUAN FIN